Did you have something to do with looking
for the Tasmanian Tiger? Yeah. Yeah,
I did know.
What do you think?
I think of all the extinct animals that
have gone extinct at the hand of man,
given the range,
I don't know if you know this,
but the Tasmanian Tiger at one point
range from Pop Warner Guinea all the way
down to Tasmania. So not just the
island of Tasmania but thousands,
tens of thousands of miles. I think given
the range, the frequency of sightings,
the amount of untouched habitat in
Australia and Tasmania and Papa New Guinea
where they just found a new dog
species by the way. They did. Yeah,
the Highland dog and New Guinea,
uh, maybe a year ago now.
Incredible looking animal like absolutely.
Could there be a very small remnant
population of thylacine Tasmanian Tiger
hiding out in a isolated pocket of
habitat? I totally think it's possible.
And these sightings, are they coming
from credible sources? So I did,
I did one expedition.
I've done two expeditions looking
for titles scene and one of them,
I was literally talking to the man who
is the head park ranger for like the
entire north Queensland. So He's a
scientist by trade, a biologist by degree.
And he says, I saw four
of them. Whoa. You know,
so this isn't like some crackpot drunk
who's like, yeah there are, they're here,
you know, this is a guy who is like
myself, a scientist, a biologist,
and spends his life in the bush. He knows
every animal in that area. And he goes,
I saw four of them.
Wow.
So like how do you not like I
get goosebumps talking about it.
Cause how do you not like
take that as credible? No,
that's about as credible as it gets. Well
look at that cool looking door. There.
It is. What a freaky looking into the
world's rarest and most ancient dog's been
rediscovered in the wild.
So this New Guinea Highland
dog was thought to be extinct.
Is that the that's right.
Yup. Wow. So this thylacine,
this area is where,
where they are.
Has there been a concerted effort to
find these things? Sort of. I mean it's,
it's one of those things where like I
would say the thylacine is like the icon
of animals coming back from
extinction for Australia. Right?
It's kind of like everybody knows about
it in Australia, they all care about it.
But where these efforts are is like
outside of Sydney or you know what I mean?
It's,
it's close to home.
So there hasn't been a lot of expeditions
really deep in to look for him and
that's what I did. So there's so much
belief that the animal is still out there,
that the uh, oh shoot, it's
the university in cans.
I'm blanking on the name of it right now.
The university itself put money
towards funding to find it.
So when you have a credible institution
like a university going, here's money,
go and find this thing.
You've got to think,
and I'm not a big conspiracy theorist,
but you've got to think,
they have some Intel that says,
look,
we're not wasting our money to look
for something that's not there.
We've heard something,
we've seen something,
we caught something on a trail camera,
let's prove it.
And so actually teamed up with did
caught something on a trail camera.
Hard to say. But what they
did do is fun this expedition.
So myself and the university who is
still ongoing with the research when it
looked in this area in north Queensland
where I went and how far deep did you go
in? Uh, 1200 miles. 1200 miles? Yep.
Took 14 hours driving and then
hiking from there. Whoa. Yeah.
14 hours on dirt roads
because this is the,
where they've incited the most numerous,
uh,
this is where that siding that
I was talking about came from,
from the biologist as well as
I think for other sightings.
The community up there is a place called
Portland roads. You could look it up.
I think it's 12 people and wow.
Live totally not like the Amazon off
the grid, but off the grid, you know,
it's all like solar energy and build it
yourself. There's no power lines, blah,
blah.
So it's just this small group of kind
of like people in the middle of nowhere.
And almost everybody in that
community has seen them. So that's,
that's where we based it out of.
And then went deep from that.
Almost everyone in the community and no
one's taking a photograph that they have
cameras, everybody's, you
know, everybody's got a
cell phone kind of thing.
But it's like, it's all, it's always
the same story where it's like, yeah,
it was there. It was late at night
by the time I reached in my pocket,
it had gone off except for the biologist
I was telling you about who said it ran
around with his dogs. Yeah. He's
out camping and he's like, oh,
there's this red eye shine and my
dog goes nuts and runs over there.
And then there's four thylacine jumping
around with my dog like for like 15
minutes. And he's like, I'm trying to get
a picture and it's like 300 yards away.
It's in the dark and without the
flashlight and the phone and like, yeah,
it's like, it's basically 100%
of those things alive. I mean,
as a scientist you can never put
that in number, but two pretty yes.
That's why I've done two expeditions
and I plan on doing more.
I feel it's out there.